christian javier on the mound for the
astros today making his fourth big
league start
and his last start sunday in oakland
that was really the first time that
we've seen him struggle
jp crawford getting ready to leave
things off against christian javier
to two swing at a best got him on a high
fastball jp crawford is down for the
first out
here's left fielder dylan moore moral
for three last night but he got on
board with a walk a block to second
stole third
and scored the only run of the game last
night as the astros won big
2-2 breaking ball drops in for strike
three
and dylan moore goes down looking
back-to-back case to start off
javier's evening that'll bring up center
fielder kyle lewis
the 2-2 did he go around doesn't matter
it's a fastball in the outside corner
and louis goes down looking
christian javier strikes out the side
mick mark averages on the mound for
seattle left-hander no wins or losses a
3.24 era in four games one start
two out no one on for alex bregman no
score in the bottom of the first bregman
hitting 257
the pitch swing and a miss off speed
down and away for strike three and that
will retire the side mark gaviche is off
to a nice start tonight
here's jose altuve batting in the number
seven spot this is the lowest he has
batted
in a game he's started since april 23rd
2012. that ball towards the middle is
going to score a run yuli's going to get
back to the bag jordon crosses the plate
and now
two bay in that seven spot has driven in
the first run of the night out astros
out in front one nothing
so they're two outs now for kyle tucker
here's the pitch swinging a shot right
past the pitcher but right there behind
the bag is jp
crawford he's got it the throw to first
end time to get tucker and that'll end
the inning
brings him alex smith one out one on
from alex
now a three and one count to malik smith
who's hitting 143. he sends one in the
air to left field
tucker all the way to the track tucker
to the wall he makes the play
white had to retreat and he missed
second base now tuba can get him
doubled up a double play as white
missed second base going back to first
had to go re-tag
and at that point once altube got the
throw from tucker he was able to double
up rather easily
two outs nobody on terretic the offering
swinging a grounder right back to
margavitches who has a beautiful save
with the glove looks like he almost
wrapped it around his back
reddick is out number three as margaret
runs it halfway to the back at first
side retired in order to the fourth one
nothing after him
one on and one away for the mariners
here in the top of the fourth
that'll bring up center fielder kyle
lewis runner on the go
machete's throw is there in time and
altuve with the tag
getting the stolen base leader in the
american league
out at second base here's the 2-0 pitch
and this one's popped up center field
playable for springer he's got it
now he just has to wait and squeeze he
does and that's it
so javier a little wobbly
but he's getting out of it here's guriel
who doubled his last time up
julian center field kyle lewis going
back still going back he's near the wall
leaps up it's on top of the wall and
gone homer on yuli guriel
la pina hits his second home run of the
year to dead
center field and the astros lead two to
nothing
one on and two down and here is second
baseman
shed long junior now the 2-2
swing and a mess got him on a breaking
ball and the inning is over
mariner said first and second and nobody
out and they don't score
now j.p crawford stands in he has struck
out and walked
pitch on the way this ball's hit in the
air shallow center coming in now with
springer
and going out correa it's correa will
make the catch in short center and the
inning is over
one two three frame for javier he makes
it through six scoreless
alvarez is singled scored and grounded
out
here's the pitch swinging a hard hit
ground ball right to jp
crawford shift working out perfectly for
the mariners mariner shortstop has it
throws onto first
four out number three runner stranded to
the seventh we go two nothing out
chad run comes to the plate again the
austin nola
james said at the belt takes a big deep
breath the leg kick and the pitch
is hit well right field cutting across
reddick and he makes the catch
and that's going to do it for the
mariners here in the seventh inning will
go to the stretch now
if the astros lead it two to nothing
here's first baseman evan white
and the 3-1 pitch swung out and a fly
ball into center field and deep going
back is springer looking up
and goodbye baseball evan white with his
second home run of the season
both of them here at minute maid park in
houston
straightaway center to the right of the
batter's eye and the mariners get on the
board here in the top of the eighth it's
now the astros two
and the mariners one on white's second
home run of the year how about that way
to go
kid that'll bring up george springer
who's over for three
margavitis the starter for the mariners
tonight did a heck of a job here's the
pitch swinging a shot diving stop to his
right head short j.p crawford
on a hop to first taken by white what a
play by
j.p crawford robbing george springer of
a hit
that'll bring up jordan alvarez the
two-minute scoring position and two out
gilbert ready here's the stretch and the
3-2 pitch swinging a ground ball to the
right side
up with the ball is crawford near the
bag at first gloves it tosses it right
out of his glove to white at first base
in time to get alvarez and that will
retire the side he was on the other side
of the bag he had a long way to go
so the mariners are down to their final
out here in the top of the ninth astros
lead at two to one
and here is center fielder kyle lewis
presley nods in agreement with maldonado
comes set hands away from the body the
o2
swing and a miss got him on a slider
good morning good afternoon and good
night to kyle lewis and that is the ball
game